thank the organizers for inviting me
here so this is a talk this is a paper
joint with my colleague Vitaly Feldman
and it's about there's something I have
to turn on or it actually work just the
wallet oh I hope it here then freeze
because actually knows Oh IBM you know
sorry about that um I think it actually
throws yeah I'm sorry buddy
oops
that embarrassing
Phil alive I'm not sure if it was some
weird interaction between very mold I
don't know this doesn't happen normally
this computer
i'm restarting here I'm worried it was
something weird about maybe i'll just
use okay okay sorry about the delay i
hope it doesn't happen again so okay
we're talking about the tracks nations
by whom toss so it's a little something
outside of the frame so we're talking
about the real valued functions on the
bouillon cube which is slight difference
not necessarily boolean functions but
the real value and question is how well
can we approximate a function f by a
function that depends only on small
number of variables
God
I early pulse apologize i think it's
something about the USB thing
okay so i'll just use okay so just to
make it clear we measure the distance
between two functions the lp norm
defined in terms of the expectation and
in this talk we're talking only about
uniform distributions on the q so
whenever there's some expectation or
probability it's over the uniform
distribution so it's mostly about l2
sometimes I will I will refer to other
values of P but for the most part we
care about approximating the function in
l2 so right off let me state free goods
theorem which is a fundamental theorem
in this area and that's a statement for
boolean functions so three free goods
theorem says that if you have a boolean
function of small average sensitivity or
equivalently total influence whereas
probably most people here know average
sensitivity is measured by taking a
random point and flipping a random bit
and checking how often the value changes
and if this quantity is small then the
function can be well approximated by
functional small number of variables in
particular the number of variables is
exponential in the total influence / the
approximation error epsilon now this is
measured I stated the l1 norm here but
for boolean functions it doesn't matter
that much we just have 0 0 1 values
I really don't know what's going on here
okay so this talk is about the real
valued functions and in particular it's
about several related classes of
functions which come from a slightly
different angle I will say a bit about
these classes of functions and why they
are interesting these classes are
submodular functions xos functions sub
additive functions and self bounding
functions and why they but we care about
these function classes well for one
thing they are mathematically nice we
can prove nice things about them but
this this work was really motivated by
question aires by balkan and harvey
which comes more from the algorithmic
game theory angle which is given random
examples of values of such a function
how well can we learn the function from
random examples and these are the
classes of functions that their eyes in
an agt of for the following reason that
these are classes that capture certain
types of valuation functions of goods so
we have some grounds at end and we
talked about subsets of that sedan these
functions might measure how some agent
values a certain subset of those items
okay so that's the direction where these
functions come from except maybe for the
last one which is self bounding
functions that one comes from different
direction but I want to throw it into
the mix because it's nicely related to
these classes and I will say why it's
also interesting so I already wasted a
lot of time so let me go pretty quickly
over these classes sub modular functions
are functions that exhibited prob the
property of diminishing returns so here
I'm a little bit sloppy about the
notation namely in the game theory world
people talk about Seth functions so the
argument is a set naturally this is
corresponding to 0 1 vector so I will
sort of switch sometimes back and forth
the property of sub modularity is that
for any coordinate J when you look at
the discrete derivative in that
direction J this discrete derivative is
non increasing if you go to a larger set
or to a point which is higher up in the
cube it can only decrease so that's what
it means to be sub modular a function is
sub additive if the value of a union of
two sets cannot be more than the sum of
the two values it's very simple then
there's a fractional version of this
condition which is that if you can cover
a certain set T fractionally biceps as I
with certain multipliers alpha I in this
fashion then the value of T is bounded
by the corresponding linear combination
of the values of s I so this is called
fractionally severity this is stronger
assumption has a smaller class it's a
subclass of sub additive functions and
then there's one more notion which
actually happens to be equivalent to
fractional sub additivity which is the
class of xos functions these are
functions that are defined as a maximum
over a collection of linear functions
with non negative coefficients so this
is actually pretty similar to something
that clean up in another talk here
suprema of random processes these are
random variables and I take the max over
some collection of linear functions so
it's known that this is exactly
equivalent to being fractionally sub
additive and at least for monotone
functions there is one point that these
functions are always monotone they can
only increase submodular functions don't
have to be monotone but if you assume
that the function is monotone that we
have this chain that submodular
functions are contained in xos which is
equal to fractionally sub additive and
these are contained in sub additive
functions
now that there's one more class that I
want to mention which is the class of
self bounding functions so this is a
class that comes from probability theory
and it's defined as follows it's more
generally on product spaces that should
satisfy the following property that for
any point X when I take the coordinates
one by one and I try to flip each
coordinate to decrease the value of the
function as much as possible this is
what this operation does and I add up
the differences it should be bounded by
the value of x itself that's what it
means to be self bounding more generally
we talk about a self pounding functions
where you have some multiplier here so
these functions are really interesting
because they satisfy the following
concentration property that they are
concentrated they basically satisfy the
same Chernoff bound that sums of
independent random variables will
satisfy in particular the concentration
is dimensioned free that's that's a very
powerful property of this so no matter
what the number of variables the value
if the function is 1 Lipschitz will be
concentrated around the expectation in a
window which is roughly square root of
the expectation the tails are like this
there's some asymmetry there and and
these functions are also related to the
other classes in the following sense it
these functions are more general so xls
functions are one sells bounding and sub
modular functions are too soft bounding
the two is just because of the possible
non monotonicity of the functional if
you take a monotone submodular function
then it's oneself quality
alright so so this is the landscape of
these functions um any questions before
I move on well so you always try to
decrease actually actually I should say
one more thing about about this so so I
don't have to make it absolute value
because I always try to decrease so it's
non negative and one nice example of
these functions are so called
configuration functions defined by
telegram so assume that i have a
function which has the property that if
the value is k then there are only K
bits by flipping which I'm able to
decrease the value of the function so
such a function will satisfy this
property and in fact this theorem
implies pretty easily telegrams
inequality so so this technique is more
general than telegrams inequality for
concentration bounds no no so a make it
just equal to one for now yeah it's a
value of F just like a function two
counts the appearance of a certain
pattern like what is the maximum
increasing subsequence or something like
that so if it's cade and there are K
coordinates which certify that that's
the case and when you look at this
expression you know they're they're only
k coordinates where I'm able to decrease
the value by flipping that coordinate
it's more generally on you know we could
be anything and you take the product
space in this talk is just 0 1 but this
is this is more general yes yes sorry so
usually one yeah when you say self
bounding it means one softball there's
also a be self bounding but let let me
not go into that anyway so these are the
relationships and
okay what is this talk about so so this
was initiated by by the question of how
well can we learn these functions when
you have a stream of random examples you
know how well we can approximate the
actual function and this was initiated
by Vulcan and Harvey who asked the
question for submodular functions they
gave a certain simple learning algorithm
which basically just returns the
expectation and they they prove that
these functions are nicely concentrated
they actually didn't know about the
connection with cell bounding functions
so these things emerged gradually they
also proved that it's more or less
hopeless to learn these functions under
arbitrate distributions so from now on
let me just talk about the uniform
distribution another interesting paper
was by gupta at all who had an
application and differential privacy let
me not describe that they had an idea
which proved useful in the following
work which was that you can decompose
these functions you can basically
decompose the cube into regions where
the function is Lipschitz with some very
small epsilon epsilon Lipschitz and if
you know that then the concentration
bounce imply that it's it's very well
approximated by its expectation so this
kind of approach can refine the degree
to which we can approximate the function
of course you pay some price in terms of
how many sub cubes you need now there's
this interesting paper which the thing
was the first paper that made a
connection between for a analysis and
submodular functions which was sort of
to be discovered out there not very
complicated but they made the first
connection and they proved that
essentially the Fourier spectrum is
quite heavily concentrated on the low
levels if you want an epsilon
approximation it's enough to take the
first one over epsilon squared levels of
Fourier coefficients and chopped off
everything above that that gives you an
epsilon approximation in l2 now I'm
talking about l two approximations
and they gave the learning algorithm
based on that so by the way Batali will
give a talk here at some point I think
at the end of October after Fox where he
will talk more about the learning part
of this so I'm not going to describe any
learning techniques learning result just
focusing on the existential part of this
following that there was this line of
work on discrete submodular function so
what that means is functions that are
only allowed to take values from some
discrete set set like multiples of 1
over K I'm mentioning it here mainly
because they were the first who proved
the existence of some sort of Kunta for
these functions and the size of the hunt
is roughly K to the K with some epsilon
involved as well so they basically asked
the question how well can we approximate
these functions by hunters and there's a
natural connection because if you know
that you can approximate well and you
can also discover what the variables are
then you can learn the function well so
so that's a natural question in this
context last summer we we did some work
with battalion pravesh kothari where we
proved that submodular functions can be
approximated by decision trees of low
depth 1 over epsilon squared as a
consequence this also gives you whom top
size 22 a 1 over epsilon squared and
then we had a learning algorithm based
on that which improves the depends on
epsilon in this fashion compared to
previous work but the questions I want
to address in this talk are more on the
existential side now what are the
Countach that are actually optimal in
this setting and also why is this work
really about submodular functions you
know is it that we need this condition
which is quite restrictive some modular
functions are quite heavily restricted
so why is it that all these papers are
about some modular functions isn't it
really about something else and
specifically when you see these contests
of size 2 to the 1 over epsilon it looks
suspicious you know isn't there isn't
there freeboot in the background really
so that's the question we want to ask
here and also how far can be really push
these results so um so the answers are
as we give in this paper are as follows
as far as these contests are concerned
exponential in 1 over epsilon squared it
is really about free goods urine so that
there's nothing very new in these
results they can be explained by a
real-valued version of free boots erm
but there's a little bit that we have to
do and I'm curious if people here go
tell me that this was known and there
it's not somewhere we couldn't really
find it but i will show you a version of
reboots theorem which holds for real
valued functions and it implies what we
need so there's an issue with how you
measure the influences yeah so I will
show that statement and let's see it's
an easy proof it's an easy proof now the
more novel part of what we did was that
we show that there's a big jump between
xos and submodular functions so for
sub-module you can actually do much
better you can find juntas which are
roughly 1 over epsilon squared variables
so there's an exponential jump and also
for xos it's necessary to use
exponentially many variables so there's
a big gap there and this proof is
completely different I will get to that
hopefully
we also have applications and learning
but maybe let me just skip that some
already wasted some time so this is the
picture again with the pretty much
optimal sizes of juntos that you can
achieve for these classes the divide is
between submodular functions and these
bigger classes these are equals yeah but
they're pretty much tight yeah so for
example this this size of Kunta you need
that even for linear functions like
additive if you have a function which
just adds up to the one over epsilon
squared variables you have to use almost
all of them to to approximate yet so
this is yeah and for xos I will mention
that later but this is tight up to this
exponent of 2 we don't quite know if
that so the picture shows how they
relate so so monotone sub modular is the
most special thing XOS is in some sense
more complicated than sub modular but
it's all it's always monotone so it
doesn't comprise also modular functions
this piece here is only because they
could be non monotone ah good so that
will be the next slide for sub additive
functions there's no no point
approximation essentially for simpler
reason which I will show so sub additive
functions are actually it's not a very
nice class in my opinion and let me show
you why to any function which attains
values only one half and one is sub out
of it okay so it's not a very restricted
condition actually in this studying a
maid for some other problems it makes
sense but here it doesn't really
constrain the function at all so so
let's just forget about some bodily
functions it's not it's not an
interesting class
so how should i plan my remaining time i
was supposed to well that's a lot that's
too much so I'm not going to i'm not
going to keep you that long good so i
want to explain two things one is the
connection with reduced erm and in
particular this real values three good
crm and the second thing is the stronger
bound for submodular functions which use
which is proved by a different technique
and it's kind of new okay so so again
for boolean functions we measure the
total influence just by adding up these
probabilities of whether the function
value differs or not and there's a nice
nice expression in terms of Fourier
coefficients for this so now when we
want to go from boolean values to real
value function that have real values
what is the most natural thing to
generalize this one would say that
probably by taking this formula because
it's all about Fourier analysis this is
a nice general formula so we can define
that for any real valued function and
that it feels like this is what it
should be but unfortunately free booze
theorem actually does not hold which is
widely known i guess that there's an
example in a paper by o'donnell and
serve video and the example is like this
basically a smooth kind of majority
function so the function stays at minus
1 and then in a window of size square
root and it goes linearly it only
depends on the sum of the excise it's a
symmetric function it goes from minus 1
to 1 linearly and then it stays up plus
1 okay so so what's the problem here the
discrete derivatives are
one over square root n no variable can
change the value by more than one over
square root n so when you look at these
squared influences the square
differences are 1 over N and the total
squared influence would be a constant
right so it looks like if free goods
theorem were supposed to be true there
should be a epsilon approximate hunt
outside 22 the something at least it
should be constant for constant epsilon
but that's not the case here you cannot
approximate this function for some
constant epsilon I don't know one over
ten you need it linearly many variables
so so something is wrong here and well
so there's this paper by by Ryan and
Rocco we're about learning decision
trees and they had to work around which
was essentially to discretize the range
so they said okay let's round up the
values to multiples of some small Delta
and then let's prove come to
approximation for these kinds of
functions so that's true that that works
there's some dependence of delta which
is not too bad but it doesn't work very
well for our setting for one thing if
you take a function and you round it to
multiples of some small Delta typically
it's not going to be sub modular anymore
and the total influence could actually
go up by by doing this so it's not clear
how to use that and also it doesn't feel
I don't know it doesn't really feel like
the right way to to state this theorem
so okay so what we did was we modified
the proof which is really the same proof
to get a statement about the real value
functions which I will show on the next
slide but before I get to that just
notice that if we look at let me call
these degree kappa influences
i define let's just remember this the
degree kappa influences are the
expectations of absolute difference is
raised to a power of kappa that there's
no root here there's no one over capital
it's just remember that i'm defining it
for kappa because i will use that later
but for this example just by looking at
the l1 influences these are actually
quite big they're 1 over square root n i
have n of them so they add up to square
root m so there's no problem in the
sense that this is not the function that
we would expect to happen good point
approximation and okay here's here's one
statement that you can prove there's
some flexibility and in terms of what
kappa you use but i think this is the
easiest one to remember basically for
any real valued function there's a
hooter which depends exponentially on
the squared influences and then it
depends polynomially on the l1
influences so there there must be some
dependence on something other than the
squared influences because we know that
these are not enough to get a nice
result but dependent on let's say dl1
influences is pretty mild it's just
polynomial so this is the kind of
statement that you can prove and I mean
I'm not going to claim it as our result
it's it's the same proof but I think
it's good to write it down so to have it
written down some notes this inflow one
you can replace this by any power
strictly less than 20 but not squared
for boolean functions this doesn't make
any difference these are all the same
and the point for our original purpose
is that these classes of functions that
we like they have nice they have small
influences in both senses actually for
any kappa
between 1 & 2 there they can be bounded
nicely um so fine I'll go on you don't
use sure so so this is the first part of
the talk in the last five minutes I'll
cover the second part of the talk
actually I have some fun right yeah so
okay so the proof of free goods theorem
most people here know it we have to
remember how it works and there are very
small differences between what we do and
the original proof or rather this is
true for mirai no Donald's lecture notes
which is pretty clean and nice let me
just point out so we defined the quanta
by taking variables where the influence
is large in some sense and that's
defined by looking at the the Kappa
powered influence for some some
reasonable value of Kappa we pick four
thirds that's not very important there's
also degree bound which is which depends
on the squared influences so we still
need that to chop off the high degree
coefficients and that's why it depends
on both kinds of influences and the goal
is to prove that preserving only the
coefficients that live inside the set
and they also are bounded by D is enough
that this approximates your function
well so there are two kinds of
coefficients that we chop off the large
degree coefficients above d this is
completely standard this is just bound
based on the squared influences so we
chop them off that doesn't create much
error and then the coefficients which
are inside which are possibly not inside
J they're smaller than D but they have
something outside of j we have to bound
those and that's where I
interactive inequality comes in so
what's going on here we need after using
the hyper contractive inequality we need
some kind of bound on the l kappa norm
of something that something is the
discrete derivative of f so we need some
handle on that and in the boolean case
these powers don't really matter so you
can just use l1 or l2 doesn't matter but
here we you know we have to put it in
the theorem so that's the reason why the
theorem depends on some other notion of
influence as well and if you just assume
that lets say the influence is raised to
the power of 4 thirds are small that's
enough to make it work just one more
point why does it depend exponentially
on the l2 influences because that that
comes from dee dee is the degree above
which we kill all the coefficients and
there's a term coming from introducing
the noise operator which is exponential
in D we need to kill that and that part
defense depends on the squared
influences but then the remaining parts
are easier to handle it's enough to be
polynomial in the other influence like
the Four Thirds influence so I think
this is pretty clear ok all right
now why is this useful for self bounding
function this is a very simple
connection but I think it's also easy
nice to to make explicit so our self
bounding function let's say for now it's
restricted to the 01 interval the values
you can bound let's say the l1
influences by the value of the function
itself the expected value of the
function itself it's a very simple
double counting because in the
definition of self bounding functions we
only count the differences where the
value goes down but then you take the
expectation over the entire hypercube so
you will count each of these differences
at some point there's just a factor of
two involved so so l1 or l2 influences
for these functions are always small
that's why it works okay so so this kind
of explains the these earlier results
and extends them to some other classes
but it's really all about free to good
steering so now to the last part oh one
more thing so there was a question about
tightness and for xos functions we can
set up an example which is essentially
the tribes function you just make it XOS
instead of dnf formula so it's a max
over psalms and for these functions we
need 2 to the 1 over epsilon variables
to approximate them well so that's why
it's tight
okay so now this stronger Kunta for
submodular function so the claim is that
is enough to pick one over epsilon
squared times log 1 over epsilon
variables to approximate these functions
within epsilon and you would need 1 over
epsilon squared even for linear
functions as I mentioned and check that
it's just the standard deviation of sum
of independent random variables so in
that sense submodular functions are kind
of very simple they're like linear
functions there's a big gap between sub
modular and the other classes let me
just say the connection with
concentration bounds so concentration is
like saying how well is the function
approximated by count of 0 variables
right constant so so in terms of
approximation by constant all these
functions seem to be to behave the same
way all the way from linear function to
self bounding functions we have very
similar bounds essentially the Chernoff
bound very similar bound so in this
sense they are very similar but if you
try to approximate by juntos of slightly
larger side this big gap emerges between
sub modular and excellent
so okay so how do we prove this so so
the proof is an inductive proof the
basic step is to prove that if you have
a function of n variables then i can
replace it by function that depends only
on one over epsilon square times log in
variables and the error is bounded by
epsilon there's something like one-half
epsilon so then we will produce this
sequence of jumps where the size of the
Countach shrinks and we arrange the
errors they add up to epsilon in fact
you don't even have to do that because
we already knew from the previous result
there's a hint of size 2 to the 1 over
epsilon squared so if you plug that in
here you get 1 over epsilon squared
times 1 over epsilon squared so in one
step you make it 1 over epsilon to the
four you do it one more time and you get
what you need so this is just to make it
a standalone through so i just have to
explain how you make this one step from
n to 1 over epsilon squared log let's
just do it for monotone submodular
function so the idea is to run some kind
of greedy algorithm because greedy
algorithms are what works for submodular
functions but it's a different kind of
greedy algorithm so the algorithm picks
variables and the way you pick these
variables is that naturally you want to
pick variables that contribute
significantly to the set that you have
already and the sense that the discrete
derivative along that variable is large
enough in some sense so the key is to
define carefully what it means to be
large enough now here's one one proposal
is to look at the set of variables that
we have so far pick a uniformly random
assignment and measure the expected
discrete derivative with respect to that
random assignment and let's say if its
large enough then we include that
variable now that this looks very
promising
because we cannot include too many
variables this way the value just
accumulate too much and at the purpose
of doing this is that the function
should be alpha Lipschitz in the
variables that we did not choose so
hopefully it will be nicely concentrated
there this doesn't quite work and the
reason is that the condition of
Lipschitz nurse and these remaining
variables is in expectation in some
sense it's in expectation over the
assignments to the variables that we
already chose what we really want is a
statement with high probability over
these assignments and for all the
variables outside of our set at the same
time so we need some kind of Union bound
here so the goal is that we want to make
the probability of failure the
probability that this contribution is
large enough we want to make that really
tiny and just by looking at at
expectations we get mark of bound or
something pretty weak so how do we make
it very tiny and here's where we use
this this lemma my old days at MIT so
with Michelle government's we had this
little lemma for down closed events on
the q the lemma says that if you have a
down closed event and you look at the
probability of this event under P biased
product distribution then the
probability of this event should decay
quite rapidly and specifically when you
look at it as a function of P it should
be a function which looks like 1 minus P
to something that can only increase with
P
but make sense this is so not very hard
to prove actually yep no no this is no
this is just the only condition is that
if something is in the set and
everything below that is also in this
well so this actually applies to the
discrete derivatives so we will use the
fact that the discrete derivatives are
monotone yes yes that is a good point
yeah so we don't use it we don't prove
it using croscill katona we initially we
had some actually slightly weaker
version I don't think you basically you
prove it by induction on the size of the
ground set you look at it you
differentiate this function and you get
some kind of the induction on this size
of the ground set and you prove that
this function has to be non decreasing
it's not very complicated but it's a
good point yes yeah certainly no no no
so the the statement should be there
exists a function of V of P such that
the function is in this form yeah
exactly yeah yeah it's okay it's a
little bit cryptic but lets me let me
say an example which makes it more clear
how we want to use it and why it's
called what we call it boosting them are
there there's nothing no relation with
like boosting and learning so people
criticize this for that by this
particular piece
so here's here's an application of the
ulema which makes it more clear I think
so suppose you have some down monotone
event f and first I look at the uniform
distribution I sample with probability
one-half and I look at the probability
of my event suppose I know that it's at
least one over two to the K for some key
so relatively small so then the lemma
says that if I sample instead with
probability 1 over K the the probability
that the event happens we'll go up to a
constant so from an exponentially small
probability of the event I go to a
constant and the price is not too bad I
just replace one half x 1 over K and
that's that's why we call it boosting my
mouth in fact for an integer K the proof
of this is very easy I'll leave it as an
exercise so
okay so i'm very happy i can i can
promote this lemma one more time because
i gave a talk here actually in 2005 at
MSR I about this one but i doubt that
anybody remembers so let me finish
Sophie's of the statement is that there
exists some non decreasing function fees
such that the function the probability
is in this form it's 1 minus P to
something that can only it can only
increase three maybe write a nice take
action now in this case you should
actually so so now I'm moving from p
equal to one-half to some smaller value
I'm moving to a smaller value of P so
the lemma says that this function f now
you confuse me if you take a solemn a
blast the isoparametric inequality
some of influence oil is always dead or
equal to the measure times no one of the
division oh then okay but these are like
pretty heavy tools for this this is very
simple yeah yeah but is also like tiny
then I mean if I'd really not to a
specific set
genuine you can go from one point to
another point yeah if I know the
probability for some P then I know that
if I go to one side it can only it will
be increasing quality yeah classical
katona is closer to this we had some
version of this which is somewhat weaker
in the parameters which uses croscill
katona I'm forgetting the details now
but it was a little bit weaker yeah so
how do we use this so so we built the
set we build the Kunta right and we
build it by by checking checking these
discrete derivatives with respect to a
random assignment of the variables so
far where we set variables to 1 with
probability Delta some pretty small
dealt with 1 over log N and we include
the element only if the discrete
derivative is large enough with constant
probability ok so the point is that the
elements that we did not include they
have they have the property that with
respect to this biased random assignment
discrete derivative is large with some
found its probability 1 over you but
it's under a biased measure with this
bias like 1 over log n so when we move
from Delta of this value to one half we
will actually make this probability very
small so we're using it in the reverse
now if i knew and i'm using the fact
that this is a Down closed event if the
discrete derivative is at least
something for a certain point then with
respect to a smaller point it
the only larger that's exactly the
definition of sub modularity so so we
get it down closed event here and what I
really care about is the probability
over a uniform distribution because
that's mine that's my target so over the
uniform distribution the probabilities
of these events for any coordinate that
I did not pick to be in the Kunta will
actually be very small the parameters
are chosen so that this becomes epsilon
over m so I pay that's that's why
somehow we save while we save a lot
because it's enough to make the
probability 1 over log n but the
probability of the event that I care
about becomes epsilon older em so that I
can do a Union bound so we do a Union
bound over all the variables that we did
not take and the probability is still
bounded by epsilon it makes sense so
just to wrap up we constructed some set
of variables such that with probability
1 minus epsilon over assignments to
these variables when I look at the
remaining variables the function is
epsilon squared Lipchitz so we we get a
very nice concentration there and this
implies that it's enough to fix these
variables averaged out everything else
and you get an epsilon approximation to
your original function and the size of
the conch titles are actually quite
simple to bounce OH the intuitively it's
the same thing we include only the
variables that contribute sufficiently
enough to the current set so the
expectation of a certain set keeps
increasing every time we include
something we cannot increase too many
times and it's 1 over epsilon square so
I think I'll just finish ah 1 okay sorry
so let me advertise let me advertise a
talk by the tally Feldman I think
there's like a day after fox or
something with talks longer talks so he
will talk more about the learning
learning aspect so I think it's here at
the assignments right so the day after
wednesday the day after fox there three
or four somehow carefully selected fox
talks on a longer 50 minute
presentations so I'll example
it's like some papers from Fox related
to boolean analysis something like that
so yeah so he will talk more about
learning learning us there's also a
question here open question so um
actually the original question that
Vulcan and Harvey asked was how well can
you approximately these functions if you
want to achieve a multiplicative
approximation within 1 plus epsilon up
to a set of measure epsilon in the cube
and these techniques imply such a kunta
but only for monotone submodular
functions so pretty much the same kind
of gun cocking actually approximate the
function up to a multiplicative error
which is more difficult but then there's
some epsilon fraction of points where we
don't have any guarantee arrow and
that's the so-called pmac model of
Vulcan and Harvey so we don't know if
this kind of punta exists for non
monotone submodular functions or no
there might be a gap between east oh
alright so that's and you get it from
the alphabet for summation
my flowers just to prove you follow the
yeah you modify the proof we have
actually several ways there are two ways
one uses the additive one as a black box
but then the parameters are slightly
worse you can you can modify the proof
to give you the multiplicative Kunta the
other thing is more of a remark that so
telegram has papers kk overdo it and
there he looks at this l two verses l1
and potato and suzanne so I mean he
shows that if the l2 the same total
equal to the small then you get some
variables which large l 2 verse so on I
think oh so maybe it is recognized it
doesn't have the kind of winter care of
them and also it was at some other norms
actually not L want so as you said you
can define to get this kappa for any
value lesson right yeah and there is a
stronger thing between these LP norms
and helpful and that's kind of the bar
where the proof fails
so what what is this statement there are
so you can measure you can define a new
plan it's not be to help you know it's a
different note which is stronger than
all these LP known for pls sm2 but still
the proof works so you get it compiles
the result or remember is that you get a
lot of very very good with larger
classes ah all the horses like a KL and
if that works it should work too yeah
why it's known for its Norman yeah I
think it's somewhere somewhere
Oh